salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésors
alors aujourd'hui l'équipe est au
complet on est dans béziers toujours pas
pour notre chargeur de ce thème donc là
on a un objectif aujourd'hui trouver
larmes
vestige de la seconde guerre mondiale
larmes des résistants le ten on va le
chercher on va le trouver
on se retrouve de suite pour la pêche
parce que c'est ça ça c'est un collier
de serrage de déposer un peu par l'avant
ou de catalyseur thing un cessez le feu
que le record
[Musique]
par contre là les plantes c'est la
misère que je descende pas si ouais
ouais c'est du vieux poteaux électriques
ça assez vieux ça c'est au moins et 50
enfin je sais pas jusqu'à quand ils ont
servi et sa mise hors sûrement pièces
mécaniques aux médecins pour le sortir
ils sont nos pires endroits et à vos
charmants voici là il est pas simple
j'ai un truc là quelques ko c'est quoi
cette merde un portail web ces portions
voyage de balcon
oui bon d'accord ça va coûter cher en
vrai c'est en bon état gros si tu
trouves un mec qui a besoin d'aidé et
comment la même sorti un pas mal aux
oraux
je sais pas si racines ou non à ses
racines c'est quand même à le piquer
alpha mos oh oui se voit ses racines
donc c'est ça ouais pas mal au c koi ça
que tu es un premier pas la langue ainsi
que si si si l homme notre appli on va
enlever cette garde je pense que c'est
réparable ça j'ai pas trop rouillé c'est
quoi ça un filtre à huile
nickel c'est quoi ça déjà les armes le
seigneur des anneaux l'aquilon les
orques à j'ai trouvé de l'engrais les
gars wendy nitrate d'ammonium donc voilà
les enveloppes ce que je leur ai pas
ouais pour monceau de faire passer mais
merde que tu avais un fouet comme ses
différents vasys ils galèrent à sortir
lire à sa bulle en mai
le principe
ces grands attend ça vous jeter c'est
comme toi là tu as fait le truc qui se
lève alors et un bon c'est parce que
c'est bizarre j'ai rarement vu ça au
pourquoi ce truc alors genre de bâches
de piscine rouler à millas de l'étang
d'âge autour je passais une bâche de
piscine ou un point chaud j'ai
l'impression qu'à rentrer dedans
je vous le mets dans le seau se trouve
à
oh c'est un beau but bien au jeu met en
face tant qu'à faire
pas le freiner sur 300 m
attends je les sais bien lourd oh bah
ouais ok tu ne chantes nogentais vase
et les vieux quand même
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bonjour jours
c'est vous qui ramasse et la ferraille
voilà entre autres alors le pendant à la
ferraille dans le dans l'herbe à un an à
la lampe à ce que je sais on le voit
vous les mettez au chellah hockey sur
les trottoirs des petits au numérique
knuble a autrement vous les mettez dans
le dépôt la marque free parce qu'il ya
certains qui pensent comme vous ils
ramassent et la faire et il ya tout dans
l'herbe
l'herbe pousser les machines on n'est
pas sale affaire alègre vous mr
d'empêcher le hamas
à l'heure qu'il est les panneaux vous le
laissez la fois confort au point de
remettre en route à deux voies
merci à vous
les mecs de la vnf très sympathiques
comme d'habitude avant renvoi pas très
sympathiques comme d'habitude qui nous
demande seulement de bien ramasser les
déchets ils ont raison parce qu'arrêter
la débroussailleuse si tu passe ici
qu'il ya des ferrailles partout j'ai la
défense a eu la tête des marteaux et des
ressorts ouais ouais c'est peut-être les
ressorts d'un sommier j'espère qu'on va
pas tomber tu sais quoi à eaubonne
monétaire en chine comme le soulève à
nice la fameuse déviation non verbal de
la guerre eh bien oui mais aussi parce
que ces cas étaient jetés
attention et c'est un morceau de
plastique et du tissu la bonne merde
mais parfait pour la dépollution à aa
oh oh oh oh allez au boulot moi j'étais
pâtit à la fois
[Applaudissements]
ouais ouais on était plus loin
à
voilà pour la faire le plus possible
avec la distance du treuil pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
installer encore quand même un peu de
marche
il vient seulement des biens en font
parfois à sortir et c'est le seul que
mouiller
ok donc on a essayé avec le treuil rien
à faire ça voilà le sol un peu trop
meuble du coup c'est plutôt le travail
qui part dernière solution la plongée
voilà on va voir s'ils arrivent à le
décrocher en allant directement tirés
sinon il va nager pour traverser la le
canal et en tirera de l'autre côté juste
faire attention qui est pas de pénis
voilà au début on voulait peut-être
demander une péniche de nous aider pour
passer la corde de l'autre côté et
changer d'angle mais bon il ya au moins
qu'elle n'a pas eu du coup on va on va
passer à l'action
il faut savoir que c'est interdit aussi
donc c'est pas recommandé de plongée à
toujours faire attention toujours plongé
à deux bien sûr je vais rester au bord
au cas où je surveillais ci a pas une
péniche qui arrivent aussi par là bas
parce que décathlon
ça c'est loin bordel
déjà au bain sauvetage réussie direct à
déjouer donc là on vient de sortir la
petite barrière et notre ami à quelque
chose d'autre
qu'est ce que tu as trop de boer a
besoin des loups clonés - croatie la
voilà enfin pas donc mais un truc très
costaud c'est bien sexy juste lol ouais
j'ai pu le tenter quand même toit à sa
bulle et ça fait pas mal oui
pas grave peut-être trop peut-être que
c'est une autre barrière
ouais c'est un caïman barrières sans
barrières non ces barrières rouges
l'échafaudage rentes les barrières une
prédiction
ouais
attendent bien là sur scène pour montrer
un peu tes muscles je vais tomber dans
l'eau du coup de barre d'affilée mais
quand on vient à peine de censure la
première savoir c'est que c'est nous qui
joue dans les barrières et qui les
empêcheront directement oui ça fait du
contenu ou vie durant vous fera un
making of des vidéos de pêche aliments
pour vous montrer ce qu'on jette c'est
d'abord il faut aller chez le
ferrailleur récupérer quelques trucs en
douce les jeter un peu partout et après
on fait semblant de pêcher à battants
j'arrive on se reprend plus tard on
enchaîne directement nouvelle trouvera
alors on avait dit sûr à 86% qu'une
barrière barrière c'est un panneau du
coup ce spot s'est rempli de matériel de
l'amérique au nom pistes cyclables et
attention double voyez c'est un doublé
du lourd et attention boss de dumping
soit d'accord mambo super nouveaux
panneaux bien l'ancien oui bon on va se
quitter là non ouais on va se quitter
l'avion se retrouve sur ce spot bientôt
bonne vidéo bon on n'a pas trouvé ce
qu'on cherchait n'ont pas trop de stand
en stand
il est peut-être ouais on reviendra on
va revenir il reste un petit peu à faire
alors je sais pas quand cette vidéo sera
posté sur ce sera déjà revenu ou pas
sûrement mais on va se le faire